the batman is finally here and based on
fan reaction and critical consensus it
will certainly stand the test of time as
one of the all-time great dark knight
stories but some fans aren't amused by
one major cameo spoilers ahead now that
the batman is out and people have had
time to marinate on it for a little
while it's not above criticism no movie
is perfect and superhero fans have never
had any problem letting their feelings
be known when they believe a work of art
can do better and plenty of people have
already taken to reddit to talk about
that big cameo toward the end of the
film after riddler is locked up in
arkham he speaks to his next-door
cellmate this individual never reveals a
name and in the credits they're listed
as unseen arkham prisoner but it's
pretty obvious who it's meant to be
you can call me
joker
the unseen arkham prisoner played by
barry keoghan references clowns and
laughs maniacally at the end of his
speech in any other superhero movie this
would be a tease that the joker will be
the villain in the next sequel but there
are plenty of fans who believe the
sequel would be better suited with a
different antagonist one redditor
kickstarted a thread talking about how
there have been too many jokers as of
late saying batman has the most distinct
and varied gallery of villains and yet
we are doing the joker again barry
kyogen who is great at anything is the
third live action joker in six years i
wish we could get villains that weren't
properly explored in movies yet the
jokers he's referring to are jared leto
in suicide squad and zack snyder's
justice league plus joaquin phoenix and
joker it's a lot of the same so to avoid
people burning out on joker's
shenanigans some people believe the
batman 2 would be better off exploring
new characters still there are those who
thought kyogen could have been someone
else entirely with one fellow redditer
writing according to the teaser website
from the post credits scene it seems
that barry kyogen might actually be hush
hush is an oft-ignored batman rogue
who's actually thomas elliott and he was
hinted at in the film itself when bruce
wayne learns what his father did to a
reporter we discovered the reporter's
last name was elliot now we know barry
keoghan won't be hush director matt
reeves has already shot that idea down
reeves revealed that the unseen arkham
prisoner is in fact the joker albeit a
prototype version who may not
necessarily be fully formed at this
point it's possible reeves just wanted
audiences to know that the joker is in
this universe but he may not inherently
be the big bad of the sequel in the
follow-up perhaps we'll get a version of
a deleted scene which reeves describes
like this it's a scene where batman is
so unnerved because the riddler is
writing to him and he's like well why is
this guy writing to me and he figures
he's got to profile this killer he goes
to see another killer that he's clearly
had an experience with in these first
two years the killer in question is the
joker in a scene that reeves compares to
silence of the lambs could we see a
scene like it play out in the batman 2
where bruce wayne is at the end of his
rope with hush so he turns to another
madman to stop him batman has an
expansive rogues gallery and fans have
speculated a future villain could be
anyone from mr freeze to the court of
owls it's a big universe out there and
it's clear the newest version of the
caped crusader is just getting started
there are many directions a sequel could
go in and for a subset of fans they'd
love to see the road less traveled check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
batman are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]